[Musique]
le métabère n'existe pas vraiment
pourtant tout le monde en parle
c'est un monde virtuel un monde
interactif
pour Facebook rebaptisez méta c'est
l'Internet du futur rien de moins c'est
assez révolutionnaire comme concept avec
le métabère on plonge dans un univers 3D
c'est carrément une expérience immersive
on ne surve plus sur Internet on navigue
ou dans Internet il faut pas avoir peur
du métavère comme concept parce que de
toute façon ça a déjà court les géants
du web travaillent à créer ce monde
virtuel un monde où l'on pourra se
divertir travailler et bien sûr
consommer j'ai l'impression que là tout
le monde joue avec le feu réalité
virtuelle réalité augmentée immersion 3D
c'est une évolution qui va avoir un gros
impact sur nos vies
le metavère est un mélange de
technologie qui existe déjà
alors pourquoi meta Apple Microsoft
investissent des milliards pour le
développement que voit-il que je ne vois
pas et surtout quel est l'intérêt pour
vous et pour moi
la seule façon de savoir c'est quoi le
travail
[Musique]
c'est déjà l'immersion totale
en portant un casque de réalité
virtuelle je suis propulsé là où j'ai
envie
mon casque trompe vraiment tous mes sens
là je me sens vraiment totalement
ailleurs
je présume que j'ai l'air un peu fou
mais moi ce que je vois c'est absolument
pas fou c'est même très beau
[Musique]
le bout du monde se trouve ici sous mes
yeux
je voyage
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très très bien fait
mais par dessus tout je veux explorer ma
passion la peinture
dans le travail c'est peindre sans
canevas quelle liberté
je suis vraiment parti de ma toile
définir le métabère c'est pas simple
normal il est en pleine construction
mais Joël Pinault spécialiste de
l'intelligence artificielle chez méta à
sa petite idée
que ça change fondamentalement notre
relation à l'espace présentement on est
dans la même pièce on se parle mais on
pourrait être dans des endroits
complètement différents on a eu des Jeux
Olympiques dans la dans les dernières
années le caisse à soi Pékin à Tokyo on
peut décider à côté de qui ont qui en
est assis donc il y a des expériences
comme ça où est-ce que pour des
contraintes physiques sociales
économique ou autres il y a pas accès
dans le monde réel ça nous ouvre à ça
lui c'est Marc Petit il développe le
métavère chez Epic Games le concepteur
du jeu fortnite
fondamentalement la technologie permet
de tout changer on peut être n'importe
où et puis on peut ressembler à
n'importe quoi et donc comme on le voit
dans les films aujourd'hui donc on va
avoir cette qualité des univers qu'on
trouve dans les films de Pixar ou des
univers qu'on trouve dans les dans les
films de Marvel
[Musique]
on va voir ça dans les expériences
interactives là c'est c'est ce sur quoi
on travaille et on en est pas loin
des cheveux
un petit peu plus long pour explorer ces
univers je dois devenir numérique créer
un mois virtuel
une barbe non trop longue
ça va des lunettes la bâtard en fait
c'est notre projection notre identité
dans cet espace virtuel c'est le
fondateur c'est notre Express c'est
l'expression de nous-mêmes et donc on y
tient assez quelque chose sur lequel on
va investir c'est sec voici Danny Boy je
me trouve plutôt sympathique
et j'ai le goût de poursuivre ce
reportage avec mon avatar
pour Maud bon enfant un avatar c'est du
sérieux qui est vraiment un sentiment
très fort qui est lié à l'avatar qui est
pas un double numérique puis avec le mot
virtuel on a entendu que c'était pas
réel que c'était faux mais les
expériences sont réelles parce que si on
se fait insulter en ligne mais on est
autant blessé qu'insulter en face à face
on vit des émotions des expériences avec
l'avatar et puis le sentiment
identitaire très fort qui se développe
et donc c'est pas moi en ligne moi hors
ligne c'est c'est moi avec mon avatar
qui vit des expériences
[Musique]
les environnements sont éclatés
réalistes ou ludique je crée les plans
de ma maison je m'approprie tout
l'espace
et c'est une table de salon avec un
immense sofa ça va être un espace
d'innovation
incroyable et puis donc tous les sphères
de nos vies vont avoir une vitrine sur
la métaver que ça soit le monde du
travail que ça soit les commerces qu'on
fréquente que ça soit la société civile
tout ça va avoir un espace dans les
virtuel ainsi qu'un espace dans le réel
[Musique]
c'est ça la grande nouveauté c'est que
non seulement on peut interagir on peut
vite des expériences 3D interagir avec
son environnement mais on le fait avec
nos amis ou nous ou nos collègues
[Musique]
enfin moi j'adore ça
l'immersion et surprenante
justement j'ai peur à tort ou à raison
que ça ne devienne un refuge pour pour
fuir la réalité c'est très invisible je
pense qu'il y a peu de conscience en
fait de ces dangers
cette question la professeure Laurence
de Villiers et réfléchit depuis vraiment
plusieurs années pourquoi tout le monde
va
attirants il y a là un jeu de plaisir
qui est terrible l'immersion va nous
mettre dans une situation ne pourra plus
discerner ce qui est la réalité physique
et la réalité immersive parce que s'il
m'est avert effectivement il faut
s'isoler pour aller vivre quelque chose
qui est meilleur voilà c'est difficile
c'est comme prendre de la drogue j'ai
dit en Sicile en 6 sur 6 heures de la
réalité pour pour aller vers un monde
meilleur ça va poser des gros problèmes
de société mais moi je n'y crois pas
au travail devant mon ordinateur les
interactions avec mes collègues sont
assez limités
mais dans l'état vert je suis avec eux
quand on est dans des conversations de
groupe des stations de brainstorm ça
c'est intéressant d'être capable de se
promener de discuter même si on est
plusieurs dans un espace immersif c'est
possible de discuter un à un on peut
mettre de l'information sur les murs
[Musique]
la grosse révolution du métaver c'est ce
sentiment de co-présence c'est d'être
capable d'avoir une discussion avec
quelqu'un à travers l'Internet tout en
ayant tous les avantages à côté de cette
personne et de partager des expériences
ensemble
le jeu et le divertissement c'est pas
mal la promesse du metaval on l'oublie
mais le jeu vidéo c'est une industrie
monstre on parle de presque 3 milliards
de joueurs
dans le fond est-ce que le métabère
c'est surtout pour eux
on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui on sait
pas trop expliquer aux consommateur à
quoi ça sert mais ça va servir à tout le
monde ça va révolutionner nos la façon
de d'acheter des choses la façon de se
divertir la façon de communiquer on est
en train de créer c'est beaucoup pour
monsieur madame tout le monde parce que
la quantité la qualité des expériences
va toucher toutes les sphères d'intérêt
on a vu la même évolution avec
l'Internet au tout début c'était
beaucoup les gens en informatique qui
s'y intéressait il fallait savoir coder
il fallait connaître toutes sortes de
protocoles même pour avoir accès à
certaines de ces choses là et puis c'est
assez démocratisé énormément
je prends vraiment plaisir à explorer le
metaves mais je suis pas naïf je sais
que ça pourrait avoir des conséquences
je pense qu'il y a un réel risque parce
que c'est plus qu'un jeu c'est une vie
parallèle possible dans virtuel le
risque c'est l'addiction et un isolement
dans ce méta vert mais également un
risque d'une vulnérabilité plus forte
mentale et physique mais il est
important que nous mettions en garde et
que nous observions ce qui se passe il y
a beaucoup de chercheurs qui travaillent
sur justement ces mécanique-là
d'addiction et ça il y a de la
documentation il y a de la recherche on
sait très bien qu'est-ce qui fonctionne
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne pas et donc il
pourrait y avoir des balises très
claires qui soient énoncé en disant ben
cette mécanique n'est pas permise parce
que elle a des effets négatifs donc faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une régulation qui
a des lois qui viennent encadrer puis
pourquoi pas un organisme mondial
et si je me retrouve dans une situation
stressante embarrassante pris de panique
on peut se retrouver dans des sensations
incongrues avec une espèce de dissonance
cognitive est-ce que ils font un bouton
d'escape c'est à dire un bouton sur
lequel je j'appuie et pour m'échapper
d'une situation complexe le métaver va
continuer c'est plus un jeu c'est à dire
que un jeu il s'arrête quand je m'en
vais du jeu là l'univers parallèle
continue
[Musique]
les géants du web s'activent
ils veulent définir l'avenir être les
tous premiers à établir les bases du
métavère
et la clé pour accéder à ce monde
parallèle c'est le casque de réalité
virtuelle en fait c'est mon passeport
tout est là pour tromper mon cerveau
c'est vraiment très très immersif parce
que là je n'ai pas vu mes pieds en fait
quand je regarde mes pieds je perds je
perds l'équilibre pour ceux qui ont
utilisé les casques là c'est quand même
assez ça peut être lourd ça peut donner
des maux de tête la nausée à certaines
personnes
et après une heure
en fait il y a plusieurs bons
technologies dont on va avoir besoin
pour que ça soit réellement agréable
chacun d'entre nous pour adopter une
nouvelle technologie il faut qu'il y a
une expérience qui déclenche le goût on
aura se mettra pas des casses des heures
par jour si on n'a pas le goût si on y
voit pas la valeur pour nous
personnellement
pour contourner le problème la lunette
de réalité augmentée pourrait devenir la
solution dans le futur mes lunettes vont
se transformer en écran j'ajoute je
superpose de l'information virtuelle à
mon champ de vision
ah tiens on vient de m'envoyer un
message
au lieu de consulter notre recette sur
notre téléphone on en a nos lunettes et
puis on voit à l'avance les étapes qui
nous sont présentées les ingrédients
comment faire la prochaine étape ça peut
s'appliquer à toutes sortes de
d'environnement et puis l'avantage c'est
que le pont entre le réel puis le
virtuel se fait de façon très très
fluide avec cette réalité augmentée
et c'est vraiment pas fini on veut
pousser l'expérience encore plus loin
grâce aux vêtements intelligents un gant
par exemple je peux percevoir la texture
des choses comme si je l'ai touchais
on a des capteurs tactiles par exemple
quand plusieurs milliers de mini
capteurs à l'intérieur de ce capteur là
qui nous donne un petit peu les pixels
du toucher qui nous permettent de sentir
toutes sortes de surface avec beaucoup
beaucoup de précisions
le toucher en est au tout début mais ça
va évoluer rapidement parce que ça ouvre
complètement les portes au niveau de
nouvelles expériences
[Musique]
c'est évident le métaver va en mettre
plein les sens et pour repousser les
limites on fait appel à l'intelligence
artificielle
on veut se plonger dans une nouvelle
expérience il faut que elle soit
reproduite de façon crédible pour nos
sens il faut que la grippe soit capable
de générer par exemple les conditions de
les passants qui se promènent il faut
qu'il faut qu'on soit capable comme
avatar de marcher avec eux à la qui se
promène à la bonne vitesse que le
comportement des objets et des avatars
et leurs naturels selon nos attentes
[Musique]
on sait gérer sans personne dans un jeu
comme fortnite mais il faut qu'on
apprenne à gérer 1000 5000 personnes ou
50 000 personnes comme dans un stade
si le métavère est un projet techno
c'est aussi et surtout un projet
financier un projet dont les géants du
Web et les entreprises valent évidemment
tirer profit
ils veulent investir pour continuer leur
influence à travers cette génération
technologique il voit la menace sur les
systèmes actuels il voit la limite des
systèmes actuels en termes de régulation
et en termes de technologie
il voit que les expériences immersives
interactives c'est mieux que la vidéo
parce qu'on peut personnaliser on peut
interagir parce que c'est social
la majorité des biens de consommation
vont se retrouver dans le métaver ça
c'est certain
d'ailleurs d'ici 5 ans 70% des grandes
marques vont s'y retrouver évidemment il
faudra payer et tout ça sera archivé
tout ça sert à faire du profilage
profilage publicitaire mais aussi pour
cibler des offres donc en vous
connaissant très bien on peut savoir à
quel moment vous proposez tel élément
tel et thème telle chose à acheter tu es
l'offre et ainsi faire la manipulation
et augmenter le comportement d'achat et
si on peut le faire sur les
comportements d'achat en manipulant nos
désirs mais on peut le faire aussi avec
les idées politiques et c'est là où ça
devient dangereux l'idée c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle présente des
risques on va avec l'IA pouvoir par
exemple avoir des avatars qui vont
détecter nos émotions et modifier leur
comportement donc il y a là un pouvoir
très fort de manipulation
de nos décisions
faut vraiment savoir que le metavère
c'est une terre s'embalise ni
encadrement et ça certains s'en inquiète
[Musique]
en général dans ces univers virtuels
ils arrivent vraiment sans défense
je pense qu'il manque fortement une
éducation sur ces sujets et c'est pour
cela que je réclame des règles au sein
du metaves c'est des entreprises privées
qui prennent le devant qui impose les
manières de faire les modèles
économiques les règles qui vont être
imposées c'est pas le fait d'aller dans
un état vert qui va être le problème ça
va être certaines pratiques certains
modèles économiques qui vont devenir des
problèmes
ici il y a rien de tout blanc il y a
rien de tout noir c'est comme dans la
vie il y a plein de nuances de gris
peut-être je suis très autre optimiste
mais je pense que ça va être ça va être
fabuleux pour tout le monde il faut que
je crois beaucoup réfléchir aux impacts
sociaux pas juste technologiques de ces
outils-là je pense qu'on va avoir des
innovations extrêmement utiles mais que
pour que ce soit effectivement
extrêmement utile il faut se préserver
de ce danger et donc les anticiper les
imaginer en tout cas faire que lorsqu'on
construit ces métave cette réflexion
soit connexe non plus grand souhait dans
20 ans c'est qu'on ait réussi à avancer
au niveau technologique et au niveau
social à la même vitesse
[Musique]
peindre c'est vraiment ma façon de
m'évader même si on me dit que il y a
pas de limite dans le virtuel moi j'en
vois une
rien mais rien va remplacer mon plaisir
de mélanger ma peinture en fait la
réalité a vraiment des couleurs qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs pas même
dans le méta vert
[Musique]